I know that you use debuggers the right
way every time and would never use print
statements to debug your code right
because if you did you might find that
tension flows print statement doesn't
quite work the same way as typical print
statements today I'll show you how
tenser flows print statements work and
how to make them most of them hopefully
saving you some time along the way there
are a couple of ways to get things to
print out while writing tensorflow code
of course there's the classic built-in
Python function print then there is
tensor flows print function TF dot print
with a capital P when working with
tensor flow it's important to remember
that everything is alternately a graph
computation this means that if you just
use Python to print a tensor flow
operation it will simply show a
description of what that operation is
since no values have been passed through
yet it will also often show the
dimensions that are expected to be in
that node if they're done if you want to
print the values that are flowing
through a particular part of the graph
as it's being executed then we'll need
to turn to using TF dot print often we
think of print as something that we add
on to the side of something just let it
run and then come back to our normal
flow of operations in tensorflow only
the nodes of the graph that need to be
executed will be executed so if you have
a dangling print node in your graph it
won't be executed so what are we to do
we need to splice the print call into
the graph like so the way this manifests
in code is to have the print call take
as its first parameter the node that is
its
input and then assign the output to a
variable that will serve as an input in
a later node in the graph thus linking
the print statement serially into the
flow of operations while the prints they
mint does no computation and just pass
the value on word it will print the
desired node as a side-effect
another behavior that's a bit unlike
what we're used to seeing in a print
statement is that the print node that we
introduce is mayor
by locking in when the print statement
will happen namely when the note is
reached in the computational graph
however there aren't really many
restrictions on what you print that is
you can print just about any node in the
graph that you can access this is the
second argument to the TF dot print call
an array of nodes to print often we'll
just use the same node as the first
argument which was that input but we
could include a lot more nodes in the
print statement if we'd like there is
also a third argument a message this
will allow you to prepend
some string before printing out those
notes so you can easily find a given
print statement in your logs so there
you have it
do you have dot print in a nutshell but
well might you utilize TF dot print in
your code I often find myself using TF
dot print in my input functions to debug
exactly what's being passed into my
training merely using the Python print
is not quite enough here since it will
only print once when the input function
graph is constructed so instead we'll
introduce the TF dot print call into the
input functions data pipeline notice now
we are just printing the same value that
we pass it in as the input but you could
certainly print other nodes in this
array as well a word of caution here if
you use TF dot print in your input
function be sure to set some kind of
limits around the amount of data that
you're passing in otherwise you may end
up with a really long log file there are
many ways in which tensor flows print
statement is not your typical print
statement but it can be used to great
effect when you need to see the tensors
flowing in your graph thanks for
watching this episode of cloud AI
adventures be sure to subscribe to the
channel to catch future episodes right
when they come out and for now go see
how tensor flows print statements can
help you get more clarity into how your
machine learning is running